you feeling good girly i never felt
better
oh really well that's that's the saddest
thing i've ever heard i know this is you
in peak form no i'm i'm overcompensating
i'm i'm going through a rough patch oh
is everything okay everything's okay but
we have a cat baby war at home what do
you mean
just the baby is crawling after the cat
and the cat is just taking it out with
bodily fluids all over the house
okay
paint the picture please your daughter
is now how old she's nine months old
okay
so she can crawl
yeah
okay and boy can't she she's crawling
all over the place and describe the cat
the cat is a half maine [ __ ]
gorgeous plus-size model cat and boy
does she know it
that's way too much information i just
have cats my wife yeah and my wife kids
and i have two cats and i just know that
we have two cats right i don't know what
kind they are
so
the cat is a big fat cat is what you're
saying yeah margot the fat guy
okay so you have this cat and everything
was fine until the baby showed up
everything was even fine when the baby
was here but once she started crawling
territory started being seized and it's
like it's hell right now and yeah took
margot to the vet because she also got
fleas and they gave her an enema
okay and then and margo's the cat not
the daughter cat okay i just want to
make sure if you're listening he did not
give his nine-month-old an enema because
she got fleece no margot the fact has
the cat have you thought about putting
your daughter down oh i'm sorry the cat
down it's very confusing and i
understand that i forget that margot the
fact that you neutered your daughter no
okay
wait wait is the cat going to go to col
all girl college yes would she go to
vassar which is now co-ed if she can get
in okay she pays her own way margo the
fat guy's the cat glenn who's also
called the peepee queen of pasadena
they're both you're an idiot
and the golden state pooper okay you
spent all your time coming up with these
cute nicknames
and uh this is time when you could be
solving the problem that's the this
that's the issue the issue is you could
be solving the problem but no you're too
busy going there's there's giggles the
tall cam gaggler well let me write that
down
what do you call your toaster there's
toasty the most
there's toasty the most
well i've got to use toasty the mosty
but first i've got to open cooley the
fridge fridge
to get the bready bread bread bread
you're living in pee-wee's playhouse
it's madness yeah i suppose it just
happens so what's the plan here i want
to i wanted this segment to end in a
real solution okay good i could use your
help margo is uh she did this to me you
can see this just
railroad track of scrape down my
forehead that's the those are the same
scratches that the murderer always shows
to the police afterwards
and says look at that hold that up to
the that's the same
how did you get these oh
cat
i have a cat
okay
oh and also i'm murdered
i fell down a flight of murder yeah uh
so we brought margot home from the vet
and i guess she hadn't finished her
enema process because what do you mean
well be specific not everything got out
and by everything i mean there was a lot
in there and so i she started scratching
in the corner like she was going to go
to the bathroom so i picked her up to
take her to her litter box which she's
been refusing lately
and as i was holding her she just spat
out some kind of pressurized soft serve
and it's just been all over the house
and it's just been a nightmare what is
she spitting up not spitting up
shat
oh
oh i see yeah i'm sorry i didn't mean to
go there but that's how bad this has
been what i'm saying is me being here
right now is the first
calm i've had in like two weeks we're on
the second floor in the podcast studio
it's a soundproof insulated uh area and
i can hear your cat outside
smashing the window open with a iron bar
[Music]
well
you know that the child comes first it's
the hierarchy of needs yes of course and
so uh
the child comes first so um cat's gotta
go by bite no we can't get rid of the
cat this cat is special to us the babies
our life
i have to go i think is the thing okay
well i'm the unmet what i'm saying is i
don't want the cat to be harmed in any
way no
but i think maybe the cat has to learn
its lesson and go live somewhere else
for well until it learns to
uh toe the line if you will you're
volunteering
oh i'll come pick up your cat
i will come pick up your cat and go for
a ride and when i come back the cat
won't be with me
and we won't have to discuss it so
absolutely not yeah absolutely not i'm
coming by at 3am
quietly through the window oh god this
is a bad idea to bring this up well good
luck with your cat thank you what's your
cat's name again margo the fat guy
incredible
you live a very
silly
life
there's our daughter mrs squeaks cheeks
for weeks
captain howdy looks so
powdy right
so
you're not a real adult person
yeah
and i'm saying this which is really bad
all right yeah that is bad i'm the
stupidest
i had my eyes open to some things about
myself hear this this afternoon